I've been there to win I wanted to walk
away
I will oh I was afraid because I saw
other people trying to do it and saw
what happened
and I remember how it went one day
you know we went this we went up to the
school meet you and him
and we went up to the school to smoke
some weed he was like oh let's get
something to drink things like ask me
what you got I like [ __ ] and if somebody
asks you that's to chip in on the drink
and you got money
and you refuse him to give up something
my house problem so I was like I got
something to drink
national yet
I mean I ain't gonna be for nobody only
drink I always say make it not only
confronted and slap you so hard though
they scared me that he was the one
running when he slapped me back [ __ ] she
seemed like he snapped the [ __ ] out of
me
I didn't even get slapped then he was
like that's me that's getting here and I
said I don't want to get it she said I
want to go through the house because
this is from the big box
you know if I won't give up no money
then you go slap me you know what it
makes you think don't we step [ __ ]
honestly Anthony bad idea I got a homie
named big we'll be there now because
there isn't he then you're doing what
you do miss they catch up to you man
one alone was argument to something
we'll do big will come outside he
figured it'd not the neck out to get
some points from you knowing that you'd
adult dealer that you gonna look out for
anyway so big will knock him out when he
wake up he actually knock him out
no me tell him big will knock you out
where the gun come in that I don't know
but the way I heard it was they gave him
good to get home but I think he went to
his own wood you got a gun came back and
he was driving down the street big wheel
riding down the street on the bicycle
and they see this shooting killing this
one dude that grew up with me man he was
like
one of the best friends I could ever
want one of the best role model as a
brother to you
because he won that nobody [ __ ] would be
wrong
my winning told him don't come having
problem to stick it down here he coming
with me ain't gonna look so bad he don't
throw no guns on Robin nobody uses his
hand he was one of my rope dog that I
knew one time he told me say SB look
just sneak over here dog he buying some
shirt and the [ __ ] told my girl some
money and even paid he's like man when I
hit that sure that's me get that [ __ ]
dog so when he I think got the water
point I said no I said no me uh let me
get a stick though it's like oh man I
ain't gonna give you none of this man
this is my old [ __ ] I pay for this [ __ ]
I said [ __ ] so you gonna be like that
[ __ ] huh
it's like man going with that [ __ ] I
said alright dawg I look this way
and when I turned my head back this way
I'm fired on you I can tell you that I'm
not the [ __ ] as I'm frisking me shaking
him down the [ __ ] I take the tank off
his office he'll you have to change was
to something and as I'm pulling this
it's like it stuck so I yank it right
I'm gonna give me a run the [ __ ] tell
me in the street even know that he I
thought I had I thought I finished him
some kind of way he woke back up chase
me tackle me in the street and I don't
know where I was like make it to sneak
up on me go then they beat will come
upon us out
I mean
when he hit that dude big we got an
eyeful big will not for just his hands
being just he was a big dude he's the
big dude here that dudes so tough man to
where it seemed like he had them from
here to pass that camera man how hard he
hit he I'm like I've seen it from where
my putting your vision once I caught up
to get the word right now yeah then when
he hit him so I'm running I get over
there huh now he was like though you
like it as we just keep all that [ __ ] I
don't need not I just got the money for
you dawg
just keep that [ __ ] it's like I'm
looking out don't you show you oh
nothing I'm hunting this up no you take
another enough even like just give me 20
as me I'm straight with that let's give
me a duck slating 20 right so this may
become fuller you'd like [ __ ] give me
something I think you ain't in on this
[ __ ] got a bag up they gonna give you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so when I'm rolling to the
gym he say man
snick ass beat and beat me out of the
money and [ __ ] I said [ __ ] [ __ ] I beat
you out of some money make it you're
gonna do the [ __ ] leg [ __ ]
[ __ ] you talking about [ __ ] we can get
out [ __ ]
I'm knock you out of this beat I said
well [ __ ] what you want to do maybe you
want to get out [ __ ] get out slowly
wine I'm squabbling something where you
trying to pull my sweat oh my oh my oh
my eyes
oh my head
I come up out the sweater I choke him
out when I get him up and look like
choking out I put it in the sleep I let
him go once he went to sleep I let him
go
Paul these pull up in front in front and
say yeah if they cook I don't like it oh
he's just sleeping right now he all
right you know you know it was like that
long as everything is cool they pulled
out like bagged up and they left snigger
woke up he's like me we gotta finish I
like dog already would you don't count
that as a weird go to thee to these
[ __ ] over here don't leave them
up for the plate some kind of way with
they play dirty they play dirty dog so
me and a [ __ ] was back at it you know
and ever I like let's be not getting to
go I was like man I'm tryna doctor they
got a [ __ ] ain't going to sleep though
think I'm hitting to get with everything
I got
I'm gonna keep going you know every time
we run in there I hit him with a couple
hits then [ __ ] ain't ain't penetrating
the summons just saying later come to
find out this [ __ ] on PCP that's why I
can't knock this [ __ ] out but he
became my boy because he never had got
asked looking like that from nobody over
here he said what he said man you really
put their hands on me you see on my
facebook I was saying I was telling you
to go in and kick back dog
you kept coming at me man [ __ ] didn't
want to do that and I really was looking
at that damn good I did good
cuz I look hickeys all across that [ __ ]
flame I didn't even know it because once
I said I said man I can't keep on
fighting I'm tired or you know somebody
get this [ __ ] man I was tired
can't keep going
if i had to give him the rounds he was I
was too tired though I smoked cigarettes
I might be [ __ ] up drinking smoking
weed
I mean I think I'm king babalu you
somebody you know [ __ ] you not and
always these [ __ ] giving me
recognition I'm fight big is like left
and right so when it came down to it and
then they needed me they know I was
there if you needed a gun if I needed a
gun all I had to do is just go to homie
I said no I need a strap man you got the
issue with this [ __ ] here but they
gonna blasting they gonna strap you know
one time I arrived with no power my
always saying look man you need that he
can't take the King around there they
sprayed up [ __ ] I didn't Rob the spot
the kill no [ __ ] I just robbed a spot
because I had a little drug problem and
I thought maybe I can do solve the
police problem by just taking these
[ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't know I was gonna
turn in no guns later and like I say it
is what it is though I mean I was
throwing my [ __ ] bad my nature's not
bite you know I walk by myself because
I've been in prison without following
[ __ ] and all I follow them floor was
for trouble now I can follow my own
footsteps and find good in it you find
something that can be serving a better
purpose in my life only have a little
bit left I don't know when God make
sending angel of death to come get me
but I know eventually it will end and
before the end I want to have some
righteousness on my side before I go
that's my life man that's just I want it
to be good I wish I knew how to do good
when I first started my life life off
but I wasn't given a lot of good when I
was growing up sorry to say that but it
is what it is and that's the way it is
you